Now that you have a high level overview of the data visualization process, let's
dive a little bit deeper into how we might start collecting data for ourselves.
>> But before we dive deeper into learning about getting cleaning data,
I want to you hear from Scott Murray again.
Scott is going to share with you one common misconception that people have
about data visualization.
What are the most common mistakes that you see people make when they're
just starting with data visualizations?
>> Well the, yeah,
most common is probably thinking that it's mostly about visualization.
Because that's like the fun, pretty, cool, exciting part for most people.
It's, typically there's a lot of like the data part that's involved.
You know, like maybe your work is going to actually be 90% finding the data,
verifying the data,
parceling the data, filtering the data like exploring the data.
And the visualization is often just kind of like that last step.
Which can sometimes be really disheartening especially if you're you know,
coming in expecting to like, make great graphics or whatever, which you can,
but there's sort of all this leg work that, that happens right before that.
So, that's kind of, I think one, one issue is about expectations coming in.